hey guys how's it going welcome to IJ
likes i'm justine and this is my sister
Jonna hello Jenna how are you I'm good
how are you Justine
welcome to IJ like thank you have you
seen first time in these videos yet yes
you never watch anybody else this week
are gonna talk about some of our
favorite fitness apps some of our
favorite cute puppy videos and some of
our fun little beauty supplies that
we've picked up this past week alright
first up we're gonna start with some of
our favorite videos now everybody loves
puppy videos and if you don't love puppy
videos and I'm you need to get evaluated
because there's something wrong with you
yeah so what's your favorite puppy video
Jenna well I actually have my own puppy
video it's my most popular video on
YouTube have you not seen it I have seen
it and the funny part is this is our
cousin's dog and they named it brie
after our sister Antonia we were
supposed to be babysitting and I was
like a pain free like you handle the
child I'll handle the puppy and I was
basically just blogging the dog is my
camera keep turning us Orange why she's
doing this
No so what you're saying is brie babysat
while you babysat brie yeah
where you do sweat and saw the babies
you get at this tractor feed and supply
store like what I didn't know that was a
real thing there's in the table when
they buy them pick one up and hold it
and when you cradle in my hand I think
that one might not be doing
you can't just buy one you have to buy a
minimum of six animal zoo ducks anyway
actually there was one video that's
posted this week by Lindsey Stirling and
pentatonix they did a cover of
radioactive by imagine dragons this
video you saw awesome we actually got to
go see Lindsey Stirling while I'm home
here in Pittsburgh we did it was awesome
check that video out Jenna wasn't
recording in except we're gonna talk
about tech and gaming although I don't
think how many games this week is talk
about other than Sim City no we're gonna
talk about some of our favorite fitness
apps because we're both obsessed hey
guys subscribe to my channel for
students number I'll be giving it out so
the 300,000 subscriber three great
calibrate this color my first favourite
app that I've been using a lot as I hate
running this app is able to train you to
run a 5k or a 10k it's called 5k runner
or 10k runner what week are you on Jen I
am on week five now day one really oh
man I'm on week four day two only race
so miss oops I said on my face didn't
really oh yeah I started I was running
late for a month before that's when I
started with likely to you click run now
and it'll tell you when to run when to
walk when to cool down and it's pretty
fantastic in 14 weeks you be on around
10k you can also share it to Facebook so
you can show your friends how productive
you are so I've been using my fitness
pal W I've also been using it and I see
every time you log in and complete your
trail for the day I know I always see
your comments like oh good job good job
go away hahahaha stop it I didn't log
today because I had three pieces of cake
it's my birthday I'm gonna sell
Hey all right I do like though like
it'll stink if you haven't sync to your
Fitbit it'll do you like your calories
from your workouts get that if you are
over your calorie count it'll yell at
you and if you're under it will tell you
eat more or your body's gonna shut down
basically and if you have the Fitbit
scale it syncs to that to the West some
circle basically Fitbit is awesome I
lived 3,000 so we're not familiar with a
Fitbit I basically don't talk about this
all the time but it's a pedometer so
it'll track your steps and the newer
ones will also track your sleep they
will track how many flights of stairs
you've climates but I absolutely I'm
obsessed with this thing I love it I
could see today
let me see I'm gonna climb 11 moving on
to our fun beauty supplies well I'll
start up so today we went to Walmart and
I thought gee golly I need new makeup
haha what actually didn't give us a
moment ago this is Sephora but this has
been my favorite mascara it's a bad bad
gal by benefit louisa i have on too
because i like to do i have never heard
of this elf collection of kohl eyeliner
but let me just show you it has a pencil
sharpener in the cap in the cat people
but the thing is like all of their stuff
was so cheated this we so cheap I'm like
this can't be China goes are we getting
punked right now this is like a dollar
it's not really $3 but like it's not
easier it's like a nice like texture
so I picked up this Burt's Bees lip
shine it's pretty sweet and pink I'm
actually wearing this and this it is a
Maybelline pink top born with it
definitely born with this lip color it's
pink and a little listen to be actually
wearing just lipstick anyone look so so
happy hmm
we haven't tried this yet but I saw
these Sally Hansen salon effects for
this glitter or French manicure she kind
of just don't even know no you put it
right on your nails so I was good back
to you guys on how this works out we
forgot to talk about our favorite things
ever
is wild fox big shiny shimmering hearts
that's so comfortable the only bad part
about wild thoughts they're ridiculously
expensive so my tip for you if you
happen to be in LA or anyplace until
sample sales you can go and get them
pretty much like 50 like 75% off
we wouldn't got these recipes at Tanger
Outlets and Saks outlet it's offset so
yeah like Outlet stores compare those
nice little star number Jenna got this
one mm-hmm
usually I have a little cheetah with
sunglasses but this butt is my favorite
alright guys make sure you tweet me four
things next week because nobody tweeted
anything good this week I not been good
this is it's me Jenna e on YouTube so
make sure you go check out her shirt on
Twitter make sure you yeah
don't mix those two up I'll see you guys
soon I think we may do a blind makeup
challenge with Jenna so look for that on
our channel it's gonna be beautiful
you're gonna look like a pretty little